tras una segunda jornada de protestas en
la que 3.700 manifestantes tomaron las
calles de Lima y tras los
enfrentamientos entre protestantes y las
fuerzas del orden quienes detuvieron al
menos a 40 personas más de 200 agentes
de la policía rodearon e ingresaron a la
Universidad Nacional mayor de San Marcos
para desalojar a los manifestantes
provenientes de distintos lugares del
Perú Quienes se alojaban en el lugar
desde hace tres días previamente los
estudiantes de esta casa de estudios
tomaron el control del lugar el día 18
de enero para dar Refugio a los
participantes provincianos hoy con apoyo
de una tanqueta la policía rompió una
reja en el campus universitario para que
los agentes ingresen y se procedió a
desplegar un correo de seguridad
Mientras tanto las protestas y bloqueos
continúan al interior del Perú como
consecuencia de ello la dirección
desconcentrada de cultura de cusco
suspendió de forma indefinida el ingreso
de turistas hacía Machu Picchu y la red
de caminos inca de otro lado la línea
férrea a Machu Picchu registra daños en
varios tramos porque parte arquitectura
fue levantada y movida hasta el momento
son más de 400 Los visitantes varados en
el lugar de ellos alrededor de 300 Son
extranjeros en otras regiones del país
los actos de protesta continúan y
anuncian que enviarán a la capital
peruana más delegaciones de
manifestantes para reforzar nuevas
jornadas de lucha en Lima